every year 2.6 million Americans
received some type of brain injury and
as a result 52,000 died and over 1
million have some type of cognitive
impairment I think it's safe to say most
people don't know too much about the
intricacies of brain damage and probably
don't think much of it unless it happens
to them or someone they know what you
should know though is there's a lot more
to brain trauma than meets the eye let's
look at a scenario that happens nearly
every day you're about to drive through
a green light when suddenly a car runs
through there red light causing you to
t-bone them upon impact the car stops
but the inertia carries you forward your
seatbelt stops your body but your head
has no restraint and his first thrown
forward and then backward the rapid
acceleration causes the brain to strike
the front and back of your interior
skull in what's called a coup contrecoup
injury the accident may be over but the
worst is yet to happen in traumatic
brain injuries there's two stages of
injury the primary injury which is the
physical impact of the brain and the
secondary injury which are delayed
injuries that happen from the
biochemical effects caused by the trauma
secondary injuries take place minutes to
hours or sometimes even days after the
accident and are much worse than the
physical impact first let's look at the
primary injury more closely the rapid
acceleration of the brain causes diffuse
axonal shearing which severs nerve
fibers and mechanically tears the axonal
membrane of neuronal cells this halts
nerve signaling at broken junctions and
causes calcium to flow into neuronal
cells minutes two hours later the
secondary injuries begin the calcium
entering the cell activates an enzyme
called Kalpana Kalpana starts to
breakdown the cytoskeleton of the
neurons from within causing cell death
to make matters worse the torn axons
begin to leak neurotransmitters one
neurotransmitter in particular glutamate
is especially deadly when released in
large quantities normally neurons in the
brain fire at a rate of about 1.1 Hertz
which is a safe consistent rate for
signaling when glutamate is leaked into
the cell space it excites these neurons
to fire at a much higher rate because
there's so much glutamate present the
neuron is unable to stop the excessive
signaling luckily the over stimulated
neuron has a failsafe to stop this
unfortunately that failsafe is cell
suicide normally this wouldn't be so bad
as it would have
a small number of neurons but depending
on the distribution of the glutamate
neurotransmitter in the brain this over
stimulation of neurons can affect a
localized area or a large region killing
more and more neurons to make matters
worse cells at the front and back of the
brain began to die from necrosis from
the trauma one important thing about
necrosis is it affects surrounding cells
by releasing harmful enzymes that break
down the membrane of neighboring cells
causing a cascade of cell death other
delayed injuries include brain
hemorrhage reduced blood flow cerebral
edema and increased intracranial
pressure from brain swelling
intracranial pressure is especially
deadly because if it gets too high parts
of the brain can be squeezed past
structures in the skull causing severe
damage keep in mind these effects don't
happen until much later
hospitals have documented patients with
severe head injury initially being
checked in as being fairly lucid and
communicative it's not until several
hours or even days later that brain
damage sets in as neuronal connections
decrease in brain cells die this becomes
apparent as patients have delayed
reactions reduced motor skills and
cognitive impairments ninety percent of
people who die from brain trauma have
documented secondary injury as the cause
and about forty percent of people with
traumatic brain injuries end up with
some degree of cognitive decline
luckily modern medicine can prevent a
lot of the damage from these injuries
for example intracranial pressure from
brain swelling can be avoided by
performing a craniectomy this is where
either a piece of the skull or the
entire skull cap is removed to allow the
brain to expand without being under
pressure inside the skull oh and one
interesting thing about this procedure
is the patient's abdomen is cut open and
the skull piece is placed inside this is
because the conditions of the abdomen
especially the blood supply and body
temperature help preserve the skull
piece once swelling decreases the skull
is reattached patients are also sedated
and placed in hypothermic conditions to
slow the harmful biochemical Cascades
now don't go around being paranoid
thinking that bumping your head is going
to cause massive brain damage it doesn't
work like that there is a spectrum of
head injuries that do and do not cause
severe trauma firstly let's look at the
probability if you're a male between the
ages of 15 and 24 or an elderly person
over the age of 75 congratulations
you're in the pool
the highest risk for brain trauma
because males between these ages are
more likely to play dangerous sports
take higher risks and be in more severe
car accidents as for old people while
falling is really bad when you're over
75 so don't do it annually about 52
percent of brain injuries were from
falling mm-hmm 20 percent from car
accidents and the remaining were from
stroke infection and general head
injuries so basically don't climb trees
wear a seat belt wear a helmet and if
you're over 75 don't fall and you'll be
okay
[Music]